[Music]
after almost a year without a major dc
or marvel release
a t delivered a blockbuster spectacle
right when we wished for it the most
i renounced my wish wonder woman 1984
did you love patty jenkins earnest take
on wonder woman
set against the backdrop of world war
one will skip to the 80s for no reason
and crank up the wacky hijinks but also
crank up the sincere romance
and while you're at it crank up some big
cgi cat fights
all while cranking up the political
allegory but don't forget to crank up
the girl power
after you crank through an hour of just
kind of waiting for the plot to get
[Music]
going
oh boy this movie is a mess a hot mess
but still
after a trip to flashback island and a
trip to the same mall from stranger
things
catch up with wonder woman she's gone
from wide-eyed optimist
to an insufferable i don't even have a
tv person
i don't have a tv ma'am you have several
wow
incredible diana is still not over that
guy she knew 70 years ago
for a couple of weeks tops but when she
comes across a magical wishing
what i said wishing rock not where would
you get that idea
oh great now i can't unsee it she'll
wish to hook up with steve one more time
not the real steve trevor mind you just
some random dude whose body she'll use
like a sex doll while his mind is
trapped in the sunken place
how did wonder woman 2 end up more
problematic than a rob schneider movie
please i'm jessica
watch this gal take down max lord a
blond-haired orange-hand con man
who can't be a stand-in for donald trump
because this one loves his son
he'll gain the wish wang's power to make
people's hair blow softly in the wind
i wish i had more help
then go full jafar and set off a climax
so chaotic
even the screenwriters don't know what's
happening what the hell is going on
no one knows any more than that what do
you want me to do i don't know what to
do
leading wonder woman to boldly sacrifice
her love to stop other people's dreams
from coming true
because we're all inherently selfish and
evil you cannot have it all you can only
have the truth
wow that is grim are we sure the snyders
weren't more involved
thrill as diana faces a new frenemy and
barbara minerva
she's a cute funny brilliant scientist
who
never mind she's a loser who drops her
papers and can't walk in heels
boo this nerd boo her nerd
watch as she copies her whole look and
character arc from that other dc nerd
obsessed with the hero who becomes a
villain
mammals a day of reckoning is coming not
that one
voila no those are disney
come on catwoman
afraid we haven't properly house broken
miss kyle
jake hi can you speak
that's my name maximilians don't wear it
out you look
amazing but no matter how exciting it is
to watch cg gal gadot drown a jellicle
most of the film is them fighting the
real bad guy of the movie
bad guys come on let me walk you home
not
doing hey there how you doing hey
they're beautiful no thank you
you look fantastic hey babe where you
going
oh you're pretty hey slow down sexy i've
had my eyes on you for some time
anything else i can get you t
me don't cat call women you guys they'll
literally turn into a cat and fight you
so enjoy a classic be careful what you
wish for story
except that no one actually knew they
were making a real wish so who cares
that you likely watch from the comfort
of your own couch while you scroll down
your phone
which will come in handy when you have
to google what are wonder woman's powers
again
made something invisible and in 50 years
i've only done it once
haven't subway trains been around since
the 1800s
and eventually how to cancel hbo max
free trial
i can't believe we killed the theater
industry for this
starring amazon wishlist
m.c scat cat durr what's a trash can
dude
i was good but i can be better a
washington dc tourism video
go there found my happy thought
and the original principal powers from
sky high
oh man i love sky high
cheetahs never prosper
how is the crown a more exciting series
about a princess diana
new year same old honest trailer guy
barbara what did you do
marmalade in my trousers on a thursday
afternoon
good eye might the worst thing about
prison
was the dementors